it has been my dream to be a person line
for any Apple store event and like this
is it like we're here we're first person
it's like honestly it's gonna be great
just leave it oh wind chill clothes wait
I have a side car I have a side window
good you really need some air
oh my gosh it if you looked like your
doghouse
we're beginning the campout we're
waiting for ED and jbjb is coming later
ed will be here very shortly
Jenna is here starting at hungry me to
prep problem is
started creeping in slowly creeping
we're gonna put some sunscreen on so we
have our first visitor here camera hey
what's up dull yeah you're not gonna
wait here though are you I'm not gonna
wait here I'm waiting for a new phone
but I have I think I know I can't I
can't wait two days Justine I'm lazy I'm
insane but there's a juice bar right
there I know it's like Starbucks and
coffee like everywhere so I mean knowing
you I know we were joking that we're
gonna do a juice cleanse
and guess what during your iPhone wait
we will not so evil food another
students are right there roll so it's
Ryu Tube channel my youtube channel is
James Cameron Phillips and my daily
channel is Cameron daily well this is
really exciting I know I was like I just
say it she's waiting already it's
literally Wednesday you guys I know
phone goes on sale on Friday morning at
8 o'clock your snack stop we had to do
it how's it go down there what I'm
really excited those we've a really
really great musician performing I'm
gonna have to go find her name because
she's impossible
you're just me like like Gucci so go sit
at a video now so I'm going to edit the
video inside of my tent I need to push
aid right now and I gotta get my iOS 8
video up time check
4214 got some umbrellas guys it's hot
right is 253 p.m. on Wednesday we've got
the third person in line so we're here
at the Apple store and I told you that I
was going to be auctioning off my phone
for charity and this is so crazy but I
met Cody here and so he heard that we
were gonna be auctioning us off and he
let me know about this charity and I
don't actually have all the information
about the charity but I will have it in
my email soon and thanks to Cody we
found it Oh got an iPhone here - are you
gonna be upgrading to the new iPhone
it'll be like that do you think that'll
be better for you well Cody was so great
meeting you you made this entire Apple
store experience so much more fun
so you're amazing you're the best let's
pitch here there you go
say bye so we've been out here and we
know time is up times it's 518 oh we got
this dude over here not always doing
he's like gambling in the bottle do you
think like I should I go join him yeah
I'm do you think here is that - whoo
he's got two hoops Hollow
33:33 where'd he go come back come back
sir come back guys I'm so excited I just
got my phone this is the iPhone 6 I
can't believe it's already out I got it
a little bit early I just naturally ran
into the Apple so I took it 8:30 p.m.
here's our line
we have another person coming to join
the line I don't remember without you
news walk fine Justin and Justin no the
other one I look I don't know
don't worry bunker I can what's
happening is it should be like yeah is
it gonna be as big as this with that
Galaxy s5 it's bigger bigger iPhone I
think finally scepter game up [__] I got
it
oh you got to trampoline I'm half asleep
I don't know what's happening it's me
just another speech yet yeah what is it
boss stay hungry stay foolish yes
oh yeah one of the best speeches I've
ever heard
I don't think it's up
time now 755 Thursday
my motivation and my spirit is really
not well my mine is not well
they just brought the barricades and 8
a.m. September potentially 18th the
barricades arrived the crowd goes wild
into the line is 1231 this machine you
got your umbrella by our hand please
show them my text that I have to shoot
myself on the Sun looks great I might
actually be joining you
maybe we should get a juice and coupons
we've officially been here over a day
this is the line so we're up here oh
hello friends so you guys you guys are
set up now this is nice yeah looks good
looks good
we've got some really crafts you think
this is a great idea tonight that's what
we have to do this is great this is oh
my god this is like a really really long
line hello hello how are you
just just visiting yeah what's wrong I
fell asleep and it's like they know oh
that's hot
it's really hot
this is the line guys I think I'm losing
my mind
18 Thursday oh my god I keep looking at
the time I keep forgetting at 4:30 p.m.
we have what 14 more hours how's it
going I paid her $10,000 to be first in
line
I did actually yeah we are yeah we're
both smart I really like your shirt
hold on I'm looking the most exciting
thing that could ever happen in the past
two days
look who has shown up to the lodge crazy
ass is here tomorrow so you guys are
really pranking along is that what
you're like your topic like this
all right good stuff I'll think of
something I'm not I'm I can't even speak
great news
when you come out you're the first one
they built no Justin you got to do
something Suzy come on you gotta do
something crazy okay we'll think of a
bottle thing all right got it like big
some controversy stuff about it
Alice make sure you know what out you
should pull out yeah I got imported iPod
we got got it but it's so much bigger
than I was expecting
look how big it is guys it's actually
really funny I do have it with me oh do
something the other side so thanks I
just want to walking back and this looks
so silly our little setup here so silly
look at this silly silly setup
we're walking back I like this just look
so silly I did
like I'm pretty sure
you look familiar that's where Ian
thank you take a picture with you
I think there's some eyes being
delivered
I was a lot of foam slowly go waiting
for
every way
oh you did yeah
oh my god oh we can't show this you got
your how are you well when I saw your
Instagram I knew you were here we're
putting you down
your stuff will go on this side oh yeah
come over here I have a question yes
maybe technically your second ignite
well we made it I was hurt because I
withdraw past and it's your vote why'd
you go outside oh you I weep are the
healthy you look great oh you get you
don't even get the first just in you
honestly I don't even care at this point
my best does I messed up Apple fun
good to see you there dude power and I
was just like let's go and see them yeah
we just drove up hot rod it was like go
say the news yay yes interviewed our
Justine and I put a bomb to interview
right and you know did you it's okay oh
please leave it cuz I did one of these
joints oh yeah
the news everyone's like oh my gosh the
news is everyone's gonna be here we're
like so far hi Fox eleven first I'm here
first on the scene yet I Shh
so guys why aren't you in lines you guys
pre-order what's up yeah I did I did I
won't get it talk to her
new contract right is 1226 warning of
the Apple iPhone release I have to get
some sleep Edie what's up man probably
gonna go take a second delay nice just
in case all right time for bed it's
about a little after midnight the stores
all closed up we've had lots of visitors
my camera is not straight because I
don't know why good there we go
6:00 a.m. I'll be awake at supper their
friends are all over there
the line is now wrapping around the
block so when the Apple employees get
her tomorrow I think they're gonna be
really shocked because I don't think
they're expecting us it's gonna be crazy
let's go on Glee destiny I'm gonna go to
Barney's and play see have fun all I'll
be here hey watch my stuff okay where's
your actual stuff it is Juby I actually
thought you were not um with us you do
not look like you were afraid I guess
he see me needle to ops is like food
Codman tells a sharp our pocket kick
Chuck comes down he's good taking on joy
it's 5:30
the day of iPhone launch feeling really
not the freshest of the fresh Jenna oh
my gosh forgot the change we sure get
you some sandwiches for our crew oh my
gosh how I would argue but I've
discovered especially oh yeah I'm good
I've been better
why I've been sleeping on the street
Oman even just to create what we do I
know but I think I'm getting sick now
that's not fun yay oh my gosh I'm very
sorry emergency you guys said 6:00 a.m.
go we tried to hurry
deliver they're coming out no no get out
of there oh my god a giant that phone is
all right it's an iPad it is a nice the
curtain whoa that's big
I made my breakfast guys the size of an
iPad I'm returning it Hey you're such a
nice man
how do you feel I feel like an idiot I'm
excited it's exciting
we're here still so making our first run
to the car to take our things I'm
actually I don't I can't say I'm sad
that to see this day and because I'm not
I'm tired
I'd like to go home now did they get to
you yet oh yeah sadly but you're close
you're close
good luck good luck I mean this thing is
going all the way around all the way
down here all the way up there pre-order
line Jaime person line good coffee got
shelter okay
and most importantly we've got the
film's reserved be fine do you mind if I
climb in there I know I didn't mean with
you getting out very cozy quite cozy
guys how's it going number one boy Oh
three more well we met some really good
friends here in line it's been a really
fun experience would you say fun all
right yeah what's the first thing you're
doing you you know what you have to go
to work
um cuz everybody excited
the enthusiasm that we have it might
look a little not enthused we are
excited we're really tired okay the time
is now I hold my phone doesn't die or
camera Jeff how are you feeling don't
care just a tired
your energy look okay I drank all that
coffee went right into a weird
apartments not doing anything
I smell like rotting feces wait yeah yes
oh yeah it's definitely
I'm Nova Cody's got the best shot don't
bro
good
okay
Wow let's pull shark
look at it
all right we got plenty I had
we're still exciting
nerves phone calls to Cody's mom I
haven't left a voicemail like honestly
five years that's like a real big chin
length
I simply this is the second phone that
was purchased here in the store today
yeah yeah so nice EU it's gonna live
from look if I was gonna get it for
anybody I'd get a full arm so you're
riding Cody here we go I wouldn't favor
here it is yeah
do you love it
so Lamar the sir Franco do you men even
line Reverend Lamar
how are you he does a lot of tech stuff
do we all know the YouTube channel I
haven't seen it yet though
all right we're leaving the Apple Store
it is now 10:00 a.m. I have been here
for us all worked out and Lamar got his
phone yeah happy
it isn't haven't shown yet you say time
on all that's our roadie got my phone
oh here we go oh we got his phone Kody
got a song by Cody talk to you soon